the vaccine rollout continues
but now with a reality check the medical
regulator has revealed two health
workers had allergic reactions after
receiving the jab on tuesday
both had a medical history of
significant allergic problems
and are recovering well thousands of
people have been immunized without any
issues
jazz a care home manager nearly died of
kobit
he's relieved to return to the
gloucester royal hospital for the
vaccine
this is only the beginning and i don't
think this should replace things that we
have
in place but i think this is another
layer of how we can protect ourselves
and each other
and i just implore people to to think
really hard and just to do it for all
the right
reasons they are going to be doubters
but i think we should do it
the mhra is investigating both cases
they're understood to have suffered an
anaphylactoid reaction
which can cause breathlessness and skin
rashes rather than a life-threatening
anaphylaxis
as a precaution it's advising that for
the time being people with a significant
medical history of reacting to vaccines
medicines or food
should not have the new jab we know from
the
very extensive clinical trials that this
wasn't a feature
but if we need to strengthen our advice
now that we've had this experience
in the vulnerable populations the groups
who've been selected as a priority
we get that advice to the field
immediately
according to pfizer more than 44 000
people have been involved in clinical
trials
six in every one thousand had an
allergic reaction to the vaccine
but five in every one thousand had a
reaction to the harmless placebo jab
so any extra risk from the vaccine seems
to be relatively small
both pfizer and biontech are working
with the mhra to understand the cause of
the reactions
this former medicines regulator said all
drugs even routine painkillers have
risks
there will be things that will be
genuine adverse reactions
and we need to bear
the balance of the benefit from having
the vaccination
with a very small chance of the risk the
problem is of course
you can't find the person whose death
was prevented
you find the person who got the
anaphylactoid reaction and so you can
get it out of proportion
just relax your arm down for me thank
you all the evidence points to the
vaccine being safe
canada has become the second country to
approve its use
meanwhile margaret keenan who was the
first person to receive it in the
rollout
has left hospital a hero after a day in
the limelight she's looking forward to
celebrating her 91st
birthday next week
thomas more sky news